[Music]
on this thursday night not exactly as
advertised
a reality check on ottawa's plan for an
international vaccine passport what
there needs to be is some criteria set
by a global agency fresh financial help
we're now in a new phase the new
pandemic benefits coming who qualifies
and which programs are about to vanish
paving the way to lawsuits a ruling from
canada's highest court on snow removal
safety concerns and who's liable
and a piano man's top prize
the canadian who hit all the right notes
at a prestigious competition
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
lots to get to tonight on covid19 travel
and government support big changes and
billions more in funding are coming to
federal pandemic support programs
there's also news about vaccines for
kids we begin with a step towards an
international vaccine passport in canada
the government says it has a plan for a
standardized document for travel and
it's not creating a new federal proof of
vaccination passport for international
travel instead it's relying on what the
provinces and territories are already
rolling out the federal government says
provinces have agreed to create
passports that have a similar look all
will feature a scannable qr code plus a
government of canada logo it's available
in some provinces and territories
already but not in others the government
says it should be available everywhere
by the end of november when it will be
required to board a plane or train in
this country abigail beeman has our top
story tonight
each province is responsible for its own
certification and depending where you
live you may already have one of these
but canada is what makes it national to
help with international travel not every
business owner
around the world may know where
new brunswick is but they do know canada
having that unifier i think it's
incredibly important you can already get
it in saskatchewan ontario quebec nova
scotia newfoundland and labrador and all
three territories we are on track to
deliver our qr code proof of vaccination
credentials
in mid-november you're going to need two
at the moment and we'll see how we go in
the months ahead how we can
bring those two together all provinces
and territories have agreed to a
national standard uh that will be an
accepted proof of vaccination for
destinations around the world but
accepted by whom a qr code here can't
necessarily be scanned everywhere we can
basically lead a horse to water in terms
of taking the
uh our vaccine apps and our qr codes out
internationally but we can't guarantee
how they're going to be received by
other countries what there needs to be
is some criteria set by
a global agency the only one that we
really have is the united nations
there are details to be worked out
domestically too the travel experience
right now is very confusing for
canadians airlines are advocating for a
government body to check certification
at airports rather than front line staff
those details are
in real time being negotiated for the
vast majority of people at the virtual
check-in where they simply have to scan
their qr code and they will get a
boarding pass that uh is
clearly marked upon it vaccination
approved so there is no actual slowdown
amid confusion one thing is clear if you
travel make sure you do your research
about what the country you're going to
requires both in terms of proof of
vaccination and any testing the airline
and travel and tourism sectors believe
this passport is a step in the right
direction but are still lobbying the
government to drop measures such as the
pcr test to return to canada in order to
return their industries to normal
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the other big news in ottawa today more
money for pandemic support programs the
federal government says it has set aside
more than 7 billion dollars to spend
between now and next may and several
existing support programs are coming to
an end as david aiken explains the
government is shifting to a more
targeted approach focused on the tourism
and hospitality industry and hardest hit
businesses
we are announcing what we very much hope
and believe is the final pivot the final
pivot it's the liberal government's plan
to replace expensive broad-based support
programs with more targeted and limited
financial help we're now in a new phase
one that is very different from the
darkest days in our fight most of the
support in this new phase will be for
travel and tourism businesses which can
continue to get a 75 percent wage
subsidy but employers in other sectors
would have to show at least a 50 percent
drop in revenue just to qualify and that
would only get them a 10 percent wage
subsidy the bar is too high and the
subsidy too low to make a big difference
for many businesses that are that are
hanging on by their fingernails support
for individuals will be limited to
specific situations for example if a
local public health authority imposes a
temporary lockdown canadian workers
could be eligible for a 300 a week
benefit we're putting this insurance
policy in place now to ensure that
provinces territories and municipalities
can continue to make the right public
health choices new democrats say the
liberal plan is unacceptable we know
that there are a lot of canadians who
are still
who are still depending on these
benefits while we're right in the middle
of the fourth wave while conservatives
have been pressing for weeks to wind
down support programs they say are
adding to dangerous debt levels we do
support programs that are going to get
us through the pandemic but we also
believe there has to be a plan in place
that's going to get a grip on our
national finances the minority trudeau
government needs at least one opposition
party to endorse their plan their final
pivot which means you can expect lots of
political horse trading when parliament
returns in november ghana okay david in
ottawa thank you the federal government
confirmed it is set to receive millions
of doses of the pediatric vaccine once
it's approved by health canada 2.9
million doses of the pfizer vaccine made
for kids aged 5 to 11 will be shipped if
and when it's deemed safe and effective
that is enough for every child in that
age group across the country the company
made its formal application for approval
this week though prime minister trudeau
urged parents and kids to be patient
young children will be given about
one-third of the dose given to people
age 12 and up
the province of saskatchewan says three
more critically ill patients will be
transferred to ontario this weekend
icu's in saskatchewan have been over
capacity for weeks now and new modeling
suggests the numbers will keep climbing
unless new restrictions are put in place
the pressure is intense not just on
health care workers but on families of
those whose loved ones are being flown
thousands of kilometers away heather
urix west reports
joanne falner does not have kofit 19 but
for the last three weeks the 75 year old
regina woman has been in intensive care
this week her family received word she
could soon be moving to ontario my dad
received a letter
just more of an information letter
saying that all all icu patients are
considered for a move there are no
exceptions a surge in covid19 patients
has pushed icus far beyond their usual
capacity so far six patients have had to
be sent out of province for care three
more patient transfers are planned for
this weekend it's tough on families and
it's quite traumatic both for the for
the teams that are having to put
patients through this and also for the
families
but unfortunately there isn't really any
other good option the province has 136
icu beds available but according to
modeling released by the saskatchewan
government without new public health
orders there could be more than 200 icu
patients in the province by the
beginning of next year
only scenarios that included booster
shots for those over 60 combined with
gathering limits project icu numbers
being brought under control the
situation so serious saskatchewan's
chief public health officer was brought
to tears i have no shame in pleading to
the public that you know we've gone so
far
and you know
we just have to pull along for the next
few weeks months and
you know it is distressing to see what
is happening in our high schools and
hospitals and i'm sorry i
you know it's a very challenging time
the canadian medical association is
calling on the saskatchewan government
to bring in new public health measures
now we cannot possibly accommodate 200
critically ill patients that is an
impossibility we will not be able to
manage that number of patients without
either evacuating them to other
provinces or implementing triage a cold
reality already forcing families to send
their loved ones far from home heather
urex west global news calgary
new brunswick has recorded two more
deaths from covet 19 bringing the
provincial death toll there to 101
premier blayne higgs calls it a terrible
milestone
these are not statistics
these are people with family and friends
i hate that we are back here after all
we have done and worked so hard to
combat covent
higgs acknowledged the anger at his
government's decision to lift public
health restrictions in july admitting
mistakes were made but he called hurtful
comments demoralizing to his team new
brunswick has the highest death toll in
atlantic canada from covid19 circuit
breaker measures have been extended for
at least another week
a supreme court of canada ruling today
involving snow removal could send a
chill down the spines of municipalities
and cities across the country in 2015 a
woman in nelson bc seriously injured her
leg trying to climb over a plowed snow
bank she accused the city of creating a
hazard and sued she lost her initial
lawsuit but that was overturned on
appeal and the case made it to the
supreme court of canada in a unanimous
ruling today the court said municipal
snow removal activities are not immune
from claims of liability or negligence
and ordered a new trial the decision is
being closely watched nationwide many
cities and provinces were interveners in
the case
a former chief strategist for former u.s
president donald trump has been found in
criminal contempt of congress steve
bannon has refused to cooperate with the
committee investigating the january
sixth insurrection in washington some
republicans believe that's because his
testimony would directly implicate
donald trump in efforts to overturn his
2020 election defeat jackson proskow
explains what the ruling means and what
happens now
with a vote split by loyalty to a former
president we need to make it clear that
no person is above the law members of
congress formally requested criminal
prosecution of steve bannon a key trump
ally
this week the committee investigating
the january 6th siege at the u.s capitol
found bannon in contempt after he
refused to provide documents or sit for
a deposition
bannon's testimony is seen as critical
based on statements he made on his
podcast the day before the attack all
hell is going to break loose tomorrow
it's not going to happen like you think
it's going to happen okay it's going to
be quite extraordinarily different like
other trump allies bannon claims his
communications with the former president
are protected by executive privilege we
know when people have destructive
evidence damning evidence for themselves
or others they're unlikely to testify if
they don't have to the refusal to
cooperate has fueled intense speculation
about trump's direct involvement in the
attempt to overturn the election
they suggest that president trump was
personally involved in the planning and
execution of january 6th trump has gone
so far as to urge other former aides not
to cooperate and has filed a lawsuit to
block the release of documents that
detail his conversations on january
sixth until you have the facts it is not
time to move on
that's why you investigate it's up to
the attorney general to decide whether
or not to prosecute bannon no matter
what the committee ultimately uncovers
about trump's involvement it's unlikely
to sway republican voters who still
believe trump's lie about a stolen
election and who think the deadly
violence at the capitol was merely a
protest against the backdrop of
investigations comes trump's plans for a
comeback in 2024 the signs he'll run
again are growing stronger he's even
planning to launch his own social media
site truth social as it's known is
supposed to be an alternative to the
platforms trump was banned from in the
wake of his lies about a stolen election
donna
jackson proskow in washington thank you
new developments in the case of the mp
murdered in britain coming up the man
who's been charged and what's known
about his background
[Music]
there is some breaking news tonight from
buckingham palace a spokesperson says
queen elizabeth spent last night in
hospital the palace confirms the 95 year
old monarch underwent what they call
preliminary investigations she returned
to windsor castle at lunchtime today and
is said to be in good spirits earlier
this week the queen was forced to cancel
a trip to northern ireland after doctors
advised her to rest for a few days
new covid19 infections in the uk have
topped 50 000 a day for the first time
since july despite the increasing surge
in cases britain's prime minister is
resisting calls to reimpose any
restrictions the numbers of infections
are high
but we're within the parameters
of what
the
predictions were what uh spy m and uh
the others said we where we would be uh
at this stage given the the steps that
we've taken so we're sticking with
with our plan
while on a school visit to northern
ireland johnson said they plan to combat
the surge with the vaccine booster shot
rollout one uk doctor that called the
government's inaction willfully
negligent over 139 000 people in england
have died including 115
on thursday
the man arrested after the fatal
stabbing of british mp david amos has
now been charged he's 25 years old and
accused of murder and preparing acts of
terrorism as crystal comancing reports
police also revealed some of the accused
alleged activities in the months leading
up to the attack
nearly a week after the shocking attack
on a longtime conservative politician
the british public got their first look
at the accused ali harvey alley was
being held under the terrorism act
police had until friday to lay charges
or release him ali harvey alley aged 25
and from north london
has been charged with murder
and the preparation of terrorist acts
contrary to section 5 of the terrorism
act 2006.
court heard that for the past two years
ali had been planning an attack and just
last month it's alleged he visited the
houses of parliament to conduct
surveillance the crown says he supports
the so-called islamic state
the british man was arrested last week
at the scene in essex mp sir david amos
was meeting with constituents at the
back of a local church ali had
reportedly scheduled an appointment with
him the mp was stabbed several times and
died of his injuries on site amos was
the only victim ali the only suspect
details about him are still emerging
while he was born in the u.k he has
somali heritage and his father at one
point worked for the prime minister of
somalia following the killing of the 69
year old mp the safety of politicians
has been in the spotlight i must update
the house that the threat level facing
members of this house is now deemed to
be substantial investigators continue to
build their case but officials have said
no other details will be made public as
it's now before the courts the accused
will be back in court on friday krystal
gamansen global news london
still ahead the volcano on a spanish
island that won't stop how long
scientists say the eruption could last
waves of lava keep creeping deeper into
a village on the spanish island of la
palma hundreds of people were forced to
flee their homes overnight as the lava
destroyed buildings since the volcano
started erupting in september in
september nearly 7 500 people have fled
and scientists say the eruption could
continue for another three months
ahead of the next u.n climate conference
cop 26 in glasgow documents leaked to
greenpeace reveal some countries are
lobbying behind the scenes to water down
the upcoming science panel report on
global warming greenpeace says the
documents show countries such as saudi
arabia australia and japan are asking
the u.n to downplay the need to reduce
the use of fossil fuels as quickly as
the draft ipcc report suggests and that
australia rejects the conclusion
coal-fired power plants should be shut
down even though ending the use of coal
is one of the goals of cop26 brazil and
argentina two of the world's top beef
producers want to remove messages about
the benefits of plant-based diets
countries are expected to provide input
but the leak shows serious pushback days
before they will be asked to make
significant climate commitments all
countries are supposed to announce tough
new targets for reducing emissions and
richer countries are supposed to be
helping poorer countries finance green
plans at this point most are falling
short
[Music]
coming up passionate performance a
canadian musician wins a prestigious
prize
[Music]
that is an award-winning performance of
chopin's piano concerto in e minor and
at the piano is canada's bruce xiaoyu
liu who has just won one of the most
prestigious piano competitions in the
world he was one of 12 finalists from
all over the world at the competition in
warsaw poland an experience lieu says
was something he dreamed of mike derlay
on the man behind this stunning
performance
for 20 seconds the audience sat in
absolute silence
waiting for bruce xiaoyulu to do
something remarkable
he began softly showing a delicate touch
on the keys to open the friedrich chopin
piano competition in poland
[Music]
three days later his final performance
ended with a flourish
and a coveted title and the winner of
the competition is
bruce cheryl
to put it in perspective the chopin
competition is akin to a tennis or golf
grand slam event except it's only held
every five years
in 2015 canadian ashar al-hisham hamilah
finished in second just like liu he was
a former student in montreal of the
incredibly proud richard remo to have a
canadian second five years ago and have
a canadian first this time this is
historic
i mean this is really historic never
happened never in any big competition
[Music]
liu began playing piano at age eight but
he says it was just a hobby
[Music]
along with another passion go-karting
but anything he did jimon says was with
an unmatched intensity i mean i never
saw such a focus such a consistency in
playing it's one of the reason why you
won i'm sure because it's not fun for
the other candidates
because the guy will not budge you
really feel that you're like
in your own world and you forget really
about everything else when you when you
play our practice it's different for the
audience no one who witnesses finale
performance will soon forget the focus
and technique of what they saw
and heard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
microlight global news toronto
amazing stuff that is global national
for this thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is from harrington
quebec just northwest of montreal thanks
for watching farah nasser will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and i'll see you on
saturday at 7 for the new reality take
care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]